Okay.
Hey,
what's going on is bill burr and it's the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
April 2nd,
2012 how's it going?
I want to say 2011 isn't that crazy?
For a month.
Then I just did some dumb shit.
I just got up off the couch and I had to close the window because I'm in New
York City right now,
sitting on a couch that I used to own that I,
I,
I sold to,
uh,
to Joey roses.
You know,
I don't know what the fuck he did to this fucking thing is a leather couch.
the kind of couch that a single man buys a leather couch.
Easy to clean up,
if you know what I mean.
All right.
I don't know what the fuck he did to this thing,
but I'll tell you right now,
I'm glad I don't own it anymore because the leather,
the leather has lost its luster.
I asked him,
I'm like,
what the fuck did you do?
The goddamn couch?
What is this?
This stuff on it?
And he's like,
oh,
you're like a sleep in here.
Sometimes in my,
my back sweats.
Fucking disgusting.
Joe To Rosa back sweat is a,
it is an album title for your,
Huh?
The couch is ruined.
Thank God I don't own it anymore.
Um,
anyways,
I'm here in New York City and uh,
you know,
I'm back here in New York City where all the real people are.
Right.
That's what I've heard since ever since I moved out to la that this is where all
the real people live.
You know,
I just don't like la man.
It's just so plastic and phony.
Oh yeah.
It's supposed to all those honest guys down there on Wall Street,
everybody tells you like it's is,
it tells you like it is in New York City.
I just saw this douchebag.
Um,
no,
I wasn't looking in the mirror.
Um,
he had on the tightest fucking jeans ever yet they were still sagging in the ass
and I swear to God,
you know,
they look like those.
Will they,
what are those things called?
Sheen's teens,
one of the tights and and jeans shingles with the fuck did they call those
things that they look like but they were actually real jeans that this fucking
idiot.
That's like one of those people.
Right.
And then he gets the shit kicked out of them.
And then then what?
You're supposed to feel bad human being to human being.
Yes,
you feel bad but you know there is a such thing as asking for fucking sit there
and jam you God damn man legs into those fucking things and then walk around
with your droopy ass and,
and just think it's,
you know,
Shawn,
what did,
what did you think was going to happen if I ever had a kid,
any Eddie's wearing please beat the shit out of me.
Close.
I mean I just can be so fucking hard when he comes home with the shit kicked out
of them.
I understand son.
I understand it hurts but you know what,
what did you think was going to happen?
You know,
why don't you just wear an itchy turtle neck sweater and I know what you're
thinking out there.
Listening right now.
Probably think,
well,
why can't somebody wear tight jeans that are droopy in the ass?
You can wear them all right.
You just gotta realize we don't live in a utopia,
you know,
I'm not saying I would do it.
I don't do things like that.
I just think about doing them.
Like when I was on the plane ride out here,
this woman was talking so loud,
two rows in front of me and she was in the aisle and I was two rows back on the
opposite side aisle and I just wanted to punch her in the mouth like through the
right behind her ear,
you know,
and just have my fist come like right through her mouth,
pushing her voice box and tongue right through the back of her teeth.
It's a violent thought.
I realize it,
you know,
I don't know what the fuck I'm going to talk about it.
I'm not gonna lie to you guys.
I did a bunch of shows this weekend and I boost until like two,
two 30 in the morning with Paul Versey,
New Jersey's own,
Paul Versey,
sometimes a jet fan,
sometimes a giant fan.
You know,
now I'm hanging in New York with the sensation Joe to Rosa.
You know who's who's dressing very dapper lately?
I got to give it to him.
He's dressing very fucking Daba.
Um
Oh fuck.
This is one of these God damn shows.
You know what guys?
Can I just,
can I just erase this and start over again?
You know what the problem is?
This is,
this is one that I would stop and start over again.
I just don't have the fucking time.
You don't.
I got go to the fucking airport,
sit next to a bunch of cunts.
Everybody's a put me in the world.
I don't know what it is.
Why can't people be more like me?
There was it made as lady Gaga.
She looks like she's like some 60 year old woman from eastern Europe.
Doesn't she?
Like she chopped firewood her whole life?
That's what her face looks like to me.
You know,
I always wondered why she wore all those mass and then one day she was not mast
and I was like,
oh,
I get it now.
It's not an artistic statement.
She was like a bird that hits somebody's windshield going like 30 miles an hour.
Okay.
That's just fucking me around.
I don't want to beat this guy.
Am I going to be the mean guy
two weeks in a row,
a little firmer.
Last week,
last week I start up,
you know,
I've got a little buzz on the Internet people all upset cause I made fun of Bob
Dylan and male breast cancer.
People got really upset by that and I can understand that.
You know,
anything else you got upset by?
I don't understand.
But those two things,
I really understand why you got upset by them.
Uh,
I played a couple of old theaters.
I was in Wilmington,
Delaware,
you know,
supporting Joe to Rosa by going on after I'm doing an hour and a Wilmington.
Delaware is yet another wonderful fucking city.
Beautiful buildings right along the water.
Right.
It's got everything going forward.
But it's one of those,
one of those cities that if 5:00 PM everybody just gets the fuck out of dodge
and all the restaurants close,
you know,
and then,
and then you know,
happens if you like checking into the hotel and it's all fucking regular people
walking around
and then you go upstairs,
right?
You eat a little sandwich or something like that.
Do you come down to get dinner?
The whole fucking the whole cities,
like there's nobody there.
Like the second shift of people,
all these Zombie start limping down the Goddamn street and you're like,
where the fuck did everyone go on now?
Is this,
is it one of these cities?
That's what I asked people whenever I go to those cities,
like all right,
what happened?
Cause you can see in the architecture,
at one point it was,
it was a,
it was a wonderful city.
You don't,
things were made,
their money was made,
women were fucked,
food was eaten,
right?
Son was watched,
rising and setting.
Everybody stayed there and now everybody fucks up.
So I have,
I think it's always one of three things.
Either the factory shut down,
there was a race riot
or,
or there was the flood of 19 whatever,
and they never fucking recovered.
Those are the three things that take out a fucking city.
You know,
it was up in Troy,
New York,
same goddamn thing.
Beautiful fucking buildings.
You could see it.
This place used to be the place to go,
you know,
I don't know.
Back in 1930 what are you taking her?
I'm taking her to Troy,
New York.
God,
Jesus.
You're going to get laid tonight,
Troy.
Right.
It's fucking beautiful.
Then I come by,
what,
80 years later,
fucking parties over beautiful buildings.
All I'll board it up.
No one can find the fucking theater and there's just that one old theater and
I'm performing there.
Right.
And people always tell you that it's haunted.
Like you're supposed to be nervous.
You know,
I'm not a big fan of ghosts.
I don't respect him.
Yeah.
Kind of like soccer.
I feel the same way about soccer as I do Bob Ghosts.
You know,
I just don't respect the game.
Okay.
Both of them are played by bitches.
Um,
I don't what I'm saying.
I was fucking sitting in a sweat on this fucking couch.
No wonder that God damn thing looks so bad.
Oh God,
what can I do here?
Um,
eight minutes in everybody.
It's just,
you know what this is like when you guys come in,
hung over for work,
right?
And he just waiting for the roach coach to show up at 10 15.
You're like,
what the fuck is going on with my life?
How did I choose this?
Why am I fucking her?
You know,
you're not going to clear something up.
Some guy wrote into me this week.
You see if I got here,
this guy said,
ah,
Jesus,
what are you doing?
I got this stupid fucking iPad from near these fucking things.
Okay,
now how do I get rid of this thing?
Can I go over this way?
No,
I can't.
That sends a,
all right,
here we go.
Is this right to so I do it.
Steve Jobs,
you fucking cunt.
All right,
Steve jobs as the worst.
Thank God he's gone.
This stupid fucking inventions every three days I got the new thing now.
Now you don't.
Here's the next thing.
All right,
really gay question.
Bill.
I'm a gay guy in a fan who was never has never has any problem downloading your
podcast.
Oh Jesus Christ.
I'd send you a free fucking DVD if he gave me a fucking address.
Monte,
you Katsu who just can't I it,
let's get to podcasters to cute download it.
What is with you?
It's not me.
My website is fine.
It's never crashed
anyways.
He'd say,
I mentioned that because in the comments every week your listeners seem to think
there is some correlation between not being able to download it and being a fig.
Um,
first this Eaton,
they're actually quoting one of my jokes.
If you haven't seen the joke,
okay,
if you think I have a bunch of homophobes I did this bit called what do you
effect?
And it had to do with,
uh,
it was actually anti homophobia,
although some gay people,
the second they hear fag,
they stand up and yell homophobe and what run out of the room.
Um,
I call that a story Seattle.
anyways,
first,
this email isn't meant at all to get you to censor or to be PC.
I like your stuff a lot.
Your point of view was hilariously balls out and usually different from the same
old comedy cliches.
But I'm curious,
with all the hundreds of things you and your listeners identify as gay,
do you really still think most gay guys are the old stereotypes on most sitcoms
and in Leno's monologue jokes out?
Jesus,
you're going to talk down to me,
sir.
Is that what it is?
Is that what you're going to do here?
Yeah,
I think that,
I think you all go like the food is hair.
Don't you guys sing everything?
He really rarely.
Of course,
I don't think that it's just funny and not to mention when we say stuff is gay,
it has nothing to do with homosexuality.
Okay.
When you say,
you know,
you like this lamp,
now it's fucking gay.
Why it look at it.
It's just fits gay.
All right.
It just means it's lame staying.
You know what it is.
It just gives you that,
you know,
anything that gives you that feeling of,
um,
it's not love.
I don't know what it is.
Uh,
what I,
you know,
I don't even know what the word is.
What does that fucking word when you're just,
you know,
when you just sitting there,
your girl,
like you take a night off from work and you're sitting there with your girl and
she,
you know,
and she,
if you,
your rent of a video,
whatever the fuck he do now,
snap your fingers and it appears in your TV.
I'm so fucking far behind a KBS,
an iPad.
I don't know.
I don't know what your kids do nowadays.
Back in the door,
you went to a day,
you went to a fucking video store,
all right.
And pretended to want to watch a fucking romantic comedy when you really wanted
to walk through those saloon doors and look at the porn off,
right.
That fucking feeling when you come home,
when you're sitting there and you've some food and your girl gets all excited,
it was like,
it ain't nice,
you know,
it does just enjoying each other.
Whatever that fucking feeling is that's gay.
Okay.
But I don't know what to call that fucking feel.
And to me,
that's gay.
All right?
Now every once in a while I'll look like a fucking chair or a lamp or someone
asks me to do something and I get that same film,
like this fucking gay.
I don't want to do it.
There's nothing to do with gay people.
All right?
So don't get sensitive on me,
sir.
I know you're not.
I know this person is not being a dick.
So anyways,
he says,
uh,
do you guys think we're all the gay guys and the old stereotypes of sitcoms or
in Leno's monologue?
Um,
is it because the ladies make you watch dope Hra and the view,
the view hags who just love having gay guy girlfriends because they love
emasculating men any frigging way they can.
Oh,
I get this guy.
This guy is a bear.
He's one of those gay guys,
you know the kind of guy you're hanging out with on the construction site.
Somebody picks on you,
right?
And this guy comes to your rescue,
fucking turns them all into a pretzel,
you know,
you're like,
Jesus Christ,
that's a fucking guy's guy.
And then all of a sudden he just sits down and just,
just something about the way he's crossing his legs.
You're like,
what the fuck is with this dude?
All right.
And then one day he just says,
listen,
I've got something to tell you.
I see what you're saying.
I get it.
That's like me being a German Irish guy and I'm like,
we're not all Nazis and drunks,
but you know,
if you put it on the history channel or if you go on and say,
Patrick Patty's Day,
you know,
you assert your defined by the worst of your group.
Unfortunately,
that's kind of how it works.
Um,
but no,
I don't obviously don't think people like that.
I saw will and grace,
then they have both ends of the spectrum.
We'll was sort of like,
you know,
just a regular guy.
And then the other guy was just like,
oh my God.
Right?
Singing my lines.
No,
I didn't.
I thought that that guy was actually good.
Right?
Why do I answer these fucking questions?
You know,
all it does it just expose how fucking stupid I am.
Um,
so anyways,
he says,
so do you still think after seeing the gay soldiers in the news and the boring
normal gay marriage activist?
Dude,
I don't think that nobody thinks that.
I actually,
some people think that.
No,
I don't think that.
All right.
I'm just breaking balls.
They're twinkle toes.
Um,
or the only gay guys.
Why?
Just going to keep reading the rest of this for whatever fucking reason.
Or the only gay guys who have been out to you,
uh,
out to you.
Really just hairdressers and interior decorators.
Sir,
how many examples are you going to give me?
All right.
Pop Up,
up,
up.
Okay.
I'm done with that.
No,
I don't think they were all like that.
All right,
so this is what it's like.
Yeah,
I understand that.
That some of you guys look like Mike Ditka add a act like Mike Ditka yet.
I don't like Mike Ditka the same reasons I do
do what?
I understand that.
So I think a lot more people do understand that.
Um,
you know,
yeah,
there's all kinds of stereotypes out there.
All right.
Look for the redheaded male,
you know,
you think I don't want to be a fucking,
start an action movie and be the guy who knows every type of karate and kicked
the shit out of people and shoot the gun.
Do you think they ever going to give that role to a fucking freckled faced
pasty,
redheaded jackass like me?
They're not.
All right.
Yeah.
Who am I going to be?
I'm going to be the guy who needs to be rescued or the guy who's good with
computers.
All right.
We all got to fucking axe to grind,
sir.
All right,
so maybe you were just checking in,
maybe you just making sure,
um,
you know,
I didn't even get his joke,
a really gay question.
Like,
I'm going to say that question was getting,
you see what he's doing.
He was like mocking me and showing a sense of humor at the same time.
You see that he was testing my intelligence while flirting.
Um,
I had a gay question last week.
I said,
what do you call a group of gay men?
This gay guy says,
evidently they're called a giggle.
A group of gay men are called a giggle.
Okay?
No they're not.
There's no fucking good way.
All Gay guys call a group of gay men giggles.
You know who called it?
Douchebags who happened to be gay?
I'm sure that they say that.
A giggle.
Go fucking blow someone.
Yeah.
Ah,
I swear to God.
If I was ever to have the charisma of a mass murderer,
that's who I would kill Douche bags.
All groups would be allowed to stay around.
But you would have to prove to me that you weren't a douchebag.
And if you then who would you make fun of?
Um,
gay men age.
Well,
because they don't have to deal with women.
That was another question I had from last week.
If you guys are wondering,
Oh,
this podcast sucks.
It's like fucking 900 grease my whole fucking apartment.
I swear to God,
it just
did.
I look at it during the winter.
I don't know what the fuck it was.
Remember the guy's showing it to me going,
you know,
it's all kinds of light.
A lot of sunlight.
Okay.
It's fucking killing me here.
Hey,
how bout,
how bout a little,
a little bit of a advertising at this point,
everybody,
would you like to hear some advertising?
Sure.
We all would.
stamps.com hey everybody.
Once again,
it's time for me to read this,
the stamps.com I try to make this entertaining every week.
Everybody,
I'm running out of ways to talk about how to get the post office into your
fucking apartment.
All right.
I have been talking about this for weeks at this point,
and if you haven't signed up,
I don't know what your problem is.
Yeah.
What do you like to punish yourself?
Like that guy in that movie about the Bible,
who took that thing and was slapping himself on the back with it,
with the spikes or that guy flogging himself.
Um,
that's when I tapped out of that movie.
The second I saw that guy doing that.
It's like there's no way somebody is doing that.
You know what kind of a douchebag is working for somebody else and beating the
shit out of themselves?
Well,
I guess those Japanese guys do that,
don't they?
They,
they fuck up.
They cut their finger off those guys in the Japanese mafia.
You know,
just knowing that that's something that could possibly happen considering them a
total fuck up.
Why would you ever join that?
Yeah.
Let's say you want to join this group.
You know,
you get a nice clothes,
nice cars,
but a,
if you fuck up,
you gotta you gotta cut your own finger off.
Hey,
you know what?
They're flashy guy.
When don't you go fuck yourself.
How about that?
Why don't you go out,
go kill somebody?
Well,
what happens when you fuck up there?
They a kingpin will you cut off?
You cut off anything.
You Fat.
Fuck.
What'd you have?
Another pork shop thought you guys were supposed to be in shape.
You like that?
That was my little fantasy interview to get into the Yucca,
Masa,
whatever the fuck it's called over there.
I stamps.com everybody,
it's important to look professional to your clients,
customers and partners.
This is the intro they give me.
Who doesn't know that?
Oh,
I thought it was important to look unprofessional.
Evidently people,
when you're in business,
you want to look good.
Look,
let's,
let's just get down to brass tacks here.
All right.
Nobody likes going to the post office.
You dread it.
It is one step above going to the DMV.
All right?
You're going to walk in there.
It's just going to be a sea of,
of a word that I can't use when I'm doing an advertisement.
All right?
It begins with C and ends with UNT.
Um,
it's important to look professional.
Placing regular stamps and your letters and packages won't do the trick.
And leaving and leasing a postage meter is just too expensive.
Uh,
take my advice.
Use stamps.com instead.
Yeah.
Why do you want to lease?
What do you want to Lisa?
A postage meter.
You know,
once again,
you serve in somebody else.
Fuck those guys who lease their meters.
Keep your fucking meters.
This stamps.com you know what they do?
They give you a scale.
They give you scale plus $110 bonus,
which includes the digital scale and $55 worth of free postage.
All right?
Don't wait.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
do what you can get.
I've been talking about this for weeks.
You can mail stuff in the middle of the night or at least get it prepared to,
you know,
after you went to some sort of free porn site,
you're like,
oh,
wait a minute,
I have a letter to mail.
I have a package to way.
You got a little scale.
It's fun.
You're what you feel like.
You feel like you're in kindergarten,
you're playing postdoc office.
You know?
Except it's real.
Kind of like if you play in a metal of honor and all of a sudden you joined the
military,
right?
You're like,
oh my God,
this is what first person looks like.
This is this is this,
is these,
these,
the post office version of whatever I just gave.
I can't even remember.
I'm still getting some fucking heat stroke here.
Anyways,
you go to stamps.com you click on the radio
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburburthatstamps.com enter bur bur are
you get $55 of free postage in $110 bonus offer,
which includes the 55 bucks in a digital scale.
All right,
there we go.
I got it out of the way,
everybody.
I was that,
that wasn't a bad read was it?
This is one of these weeks where I'm just going to have to read everything and
maybe this will spawn something funny.
It could be out of breath.
That's when you know you're bombing on your own podcast,
you know,
um,
hey bill,
this,
this is entitled,
afraid to break up with girlfriend.
I'm going to read slow,
so this takes up as much time as possible.
A bill.
Um,
I'd like to get your advice on something.
I've been dating my girlfriend for almost a year now and I've been thinking
about breaking up with her.
Well,
it's time to break up with their sir.
All right.
Dating Dayton for a year.
You know you have to still even thinking about breaking it.
It's time.
Okay.
I says we get along fine and we rarely argue.
I was just thinking of a great,
a great way to break up with someone they should invent like a breakup suit,
right?
Just something where you just cannot get injured and you just put the thing on
with the fucking helmet.
You don't wear the helmet,
you just put the ones he zip up on and which totally protects everything.
Right?
And then you get in the passenger seat and you let her drive.
Oh,
why are you gonna let me drive?
Why did you just drive tonight?
But you always liked to drive honey.
You just drive.
Okay,
why are you wearing that suit?
It's all gonna make sense in about five miles.
Right?
You get out on the fucking highway and he just started talking to her and not
to,
no way.
He just put the helmet on,
you know,
when she says,
what are you doing?
And just say,
listen,
I didn't want to go out with you anymore.
And then she goes,
what?
And you go,
hey,
watch this.
He just opened the door and you roll out of the fucking car and that's it.
You're out.
You know,
type up a fake police report.
You're telling me you died.
Then she feels bad for you.
You don't have to deal with any sort of repercussions.
Um,
anyways,
he says we get along fine and we rarely argue,
but I'm starting to realize I don't really want to be with her for the long
haul.
And we started dating,
oh,
this fucking thing.
It's these iPads suck by the way.
All right.
You know what an Ipad is?
It's,
it's a fucking laptop for pussies.
What's a matter?
You laptop is too heavy.
You fucking douchebag this thing doesn't have a keyboard.
It's got nothing.
You think that they don't know how to make this thing into a fucking laptop
already.
Of course they do.
This is this Steve jobs way of doing things rather than just giving you the
whole fucking thing.
He's going to give you 10 inch increments like a God damn drug dealer.
You know I,
that's why I haven't bought one of these yet.
This is knee is by the way,
borrowed this fucking thing and I am not enjoying it as you can tell is I'm
throwing a temper tantrum here.
You know what?
I'm going to buy a fucking IPAD.
I'm going to buy it when it is a laptop.
When it gives a little light laptop.
Until then I'm not,
I'm not having this fucking this.
This is like a,
this is like when you,
you know you go,
I know I really want to get the new Camaro and then you get the one with the v
six engine rather than getting the full out one with the stick shift,
which is a laptop,
right.
It's too heavy,
you know,
fucking deuce.
Do Shoulders at the gym next time you do that.
Okay.
Maybe do that.
Maybe to do some stuff to build up your risks.
Oh God.
Bill.
Can you get through the question?
All right.
Uh,
well,
um,
he says,
uh,
when we first started dating,
I loved hanging out with her,
but I'm just not into it anymore.
Does that make me an asshole?
No,
it doesn't.
Why would your own true feelings make you an Asshole,
sir?
How awful were your parents?
Um,
he says,
I'm 23 years old with the somewhat,
why am I,
you know,
I'm a really being a cunt this week,
guys asking for my advice.
Let's just try to bring the anger down.
Bill,
you're frustrated.
It's fucking hot in here.
You can't open the window because you say,
cut too much.
This building's a co op and they'll kick you out.
Okay?
That's what's going on here.
It has nothing to do with this person.
Okay?
It's want you to just try to be a nice guy.
So I should have done off the Mike.
Like I'm scolding myself.
Just try to be a nice guy.
Let's not take out your bad day on everyone else.
Okay?
You're embarrassing me.
All right.
I'm 23 years old,
but somewhat of a decent job and really just want to go back to being single for
awhile.
Exactly.
Dude,
you're 23 years old.
Dude.
You're fucking movie star at that age.
I don't care what you're doing for a living.
Should definitely be single.
I said,
the problem is she's got a lot less,
she's got a lot of stress in her life right now,
if not your problem.
She's finishing nursing school and trying to find a job.
All right,
well tell her to put on the outfit Banger one more time and hey,
watch this.
You bail out of the car.
Uh,
um.
Anyways.
He says,
oh,
and she has a history of depression over the past year.
I feel like she's becoming emotionally dependent on me.
Like I'm keeping her going or something.
Well,
Jesus Christ,
no one do you want to get rid of her?
You don't want this.
You know,
you want something that someone that's going to be fun to be around.
You don't want her,
you know,
it's sunny out and she's like,
it's raining out the fucking head under the pillow.
Yeah.
One of these days,
you know,
you stay with that long enough,
one of these days you're just going to,
he's going to smother with that pillow is anyways.
So how do I go about breaking up with her while causing the least amount of
damage?
Uh,
he said also she always leaves some of her shit in my apartment.
Yes.
Cause she's,
she wants to fucking,
okay.
Oh,
she's clinging onto you.
It says close blanket.
Other random shit.
I tried to get her to take a shit home with her,
but how do I avoid after,
uh,
the after break up coming over to get my stuff.
I hate that.
Anyway.
Go Fuck Yourself.
All right,
look,
there's no way.
There's no easy way to break up with somebody.
All right.
There's just easier ways.
Uh,
the sooner the better.
MMM.
Oh Diane,
I'll do this is like,
this is like dismantling a bomb.
So you know,
what you would like to do is say,
Hey,
can you come by today?
I want to talk to you about something.
Right.
And always share.
I'll be right over.
And I immediately just take out a box,
put all of her shit in it,
tape it up,
and then she rings the bell being bomb.
You opened the door,
he got,
yeah,
don't want to date you anymore.
And he just handed the box and close the door.
Right.
Dude,
there's money to be made in this man.
Does anybody have a professional breakup service?
That's such a pussy thing to do,
but that would be phenomenal.
You know it,
you feel,
you make a person feel like they got fired.
You're like when a corporation fires you and just to security people,
show up,
you know,
confiscate your computer and then escort you out of the building.
Would that be great?
Do,
that's what you should do.
Just hire to your friends to dress up.
Like security guards.
Tell her you want to break up,
you know,
and then they have all their shit in the box.
Then they escort,
escort or right out of your apartment building.
Like she got fired.
It come off as professional rather than like personal.
Um,
okay.
How do you go about breaking up with it?
You know what I would do,
I wouldn't put all our shit in the box because that's going to come off cold,
you know,
and you don't want to hurt her feelings like that.
So I would just,
uh,
oh fuck it.
I don't know.
I don't know how to do it.
Why did I drink last night?
And then I got up and did opie and Anthony,
what the fuck?
Cause Ron with me,
I knew I had a podcast to do yet.
You're embarrassing me.
Um,
I don't,
I don't fucking know.
Have a come over and just say,
listen.
Um,
I'm not happy.
Oh,
that's a great one.
That's a classic.
You know,
like if you were a singer songwriter the second he said that the whole crowd
would start applauding,
recognizing the big hit,
you know,
above all the girls I do before,
they all start fucking clapping.
You know,
if they just came out,
you just did classic breakup monologues.
Okay,
listen,
um,
I'm just not happy everyone just at smattering of applause.
You wait for it to die down.
Let the orchestra come around again.
She jumped back in on the one,
um,
match.
Tell you're not happy.
I'm not happy anymore.
And Dude,
let me tell you something.
Her being depressed is not your fucking problem.
All right?
Her being depressed is the fucking problem.
How can you do this to me?
Do you mean how can I do this too?
You don't want to be worse.
If I fucking stayed with you and I didn't love you,
I don't love you anymore.
I don't love you.
Depressed whore.
I just called you a whore as a generic term.
You know,
I don't,
I'm,
I'm not happy.
I want to,
okay.
I just feel like I want to be single right now.
I just feel like I'm going to be with you in long haul.
Uh,
we'll just be wasting each other's time.
My time is important and so is yours.
All right?
I don't want to go anymore,
but I'll tell you what.
If you go to stamps.com,
they'll give you $55 free stamps to the scale.
Okay?
That's what you do.
Just tag every mean thing you say with all the advertising.
Okay.
You know,
if you go to amazon.com so bill burrs website,
you know,
click on the Little Amazon banner,
whatever you buy,
you know,
portion of that money goes back to bill burn.
Then the percentage of that goes to the wounded warriors project.
So I know I'm breaking up with you right now,
but you could,
we could also support the troops,
right,
sir?
Look,
there's no fucking easy way to do this.
And you're going to be sitting there.
How many more holidays?
How many more birthdays?
How many more Christmases,
which is a holiday?
Sorry,
you always need three examples.
Do you want to go through with this person?
How many more times do you want to go out and rent bikes?
Go to a picnic,
sit there on a sunny day.
Is she sitting there with that cloud over a fucking head?
You know,
dude,
you know,
don't do that to yourself.
You want to fucking people who are just wonderful human beings and they just end
up with assholes.
I swear to God,
assholes.
They look for wonderful human beings because other assholes are not going to put
up with them.
You know,
so you need to be an ass hole here at,
you know,
the,
the how society looks as an,
as an asshole.
Like you're being selfish,
not being selfish,
all right?
Choose yourself,
choose your own fucking life dumper and get on with your life.
You don't,
this is what you do.
You get yourself by six a fucking Pale Ale or whatever beer you like.
You stick a couple of glasses in the fucking freezer.
All right?
Like anticipation of this championship that you know you're going to win.
You know,
like they did in the red sox dugout when they had the champagne on ice in game
six in 1986 before they had to quickly wheel it out,
okay?
Except you're not going to let this one go through your leg,
sir.
You kicking this one right?
The cunt and you'd taken home the fucking championship and when it's over all
you got to be just thinking about those frosty fucking bruise in the fridge.
Just think about that.
Just look at the clock when she walks in.
All right.
Let's say she comes in at 10 past to just say to yourself,
worst case scenario by three fucking 30.
Okay,
I'm going to be sitting down in this fucking couch,
all right.
With my goddamn phone off,
drinking a couple of five or six of these things
and then that's it.
All right,
and then don't fucking have a post breakup sex.
Don't do that.
Cause then she'll think that you're back together again.
Fuck all of that.
Yeah,
they gotta come by.
my staff.
Okay.
When do you want to come by?
This is coming off really cold.
She's going to do all of that and just try to keep dragging you back into the
fucking thing.
Um,
okay.
I don't know if this is a punk thing to do,
but after you break up with,
they just don't answer the phone when she calls and then she'll find,
just say,
listen,
I gotta I gotta come by and get my stuff.
Can you text her back?
I fucking just be a man.
What is she going to do?
Body Slam you.
She's just going to make you feel bad.
All right.
Ooh.
Is it blue?
You would do.
No,
it's cause you're a mopey.
You're sucking the life out of me.
You know when,
when you get that sad look on your face,
you look like a muppet there.
I said it all right.
There's your shit over there in the corner.
I've got a couple of cool ones in the fridge,
so why don't you do me a favor.
All right,
get over there.
Bend Down,
lift with your knees,
get your shit and get the fuck outta here.
When you say that,
touch your prince charming is out there somewhere.
You know and ain't here.
I'm not riding that horse anymore.
Okay?
I just shot it in the back of the head.
It's over.
Okay,
so why don't you trudge on Outta here.
They have fucking Cinderella.
Go look in a mirror.
I go climb up in a tower and fucking drop your hair out.
Whatever the fuck he supposed to do.
Kiss a frog.
All right.
I got drinking to do
bait it.
Something like that.
Like I said,
all that bullshit.
I said 10 past two with Sova by three 30 by three 30 at Booz Allen.
All right.
I don't know
now the fucking brutal breaking up with somebody and as brutal as the awfulness
of this fucking podcast,
but other than that,
oh Jesus fucking Christ.
This is the longest,
you know what kills me is at the end of all this horrible fucking podcast,
I then have to get into a fucking rent a car and I have to drive my ass out to
the God damn airport to yet again fly across this goddamn country.
This is the worst flight.
You know,
you only flight worst and flying across this country is the flight that crashes.
Yeah.
And I got to admit,
I'm not even gonna say that doesn't fucking Jinxing my flight.
Can you imagine that if I use,
I don't care if this one does.
And then it did get,
imagine that and then they,
everybody,
okay.
See he said he didn't care if his plane crashed coming up next,
the story of a Canadian.
Oh pray that is blank crash.
And he took 250 innocent people with the,
yeah.
Janice,
do you have a story?
No,
it appears he was doing a podcast and he had a problem with the heat,
the apartment,
which then led to him talking about his flight.
It was during that rat.
Sorry,
we lost your current.
Okay.
You took too long to get to the point as usual.
That's why you're still out in the field.
I'm Ed.
You guys see that they're going to do anchorman two.
Am I the only person,
other person who's as excited as hell about that?
Ron Burgundy is coming back.
Uh,
the man who started at all.
Um,
anyways,
here we go.
A representative for Massachusetts and Colorado.
Here's a wonderful story.
Everybody.
Hey,
their belt.
Just want to tell you about,
oh Jeez.
Hey.
Hey there.
Bill.
Just wanted to tell about how you,
how you,
one of your fellow you fucking cunts.
Can you,
can you,
okay.
I swear to God,
you guys do this on purpose.
You know,
I suck at reading out loud and then just wanted to tell you what you want to
tell about how you,
one of your fellow Massachusetts people,
which word do I take out there,
sir?
Okay.
Just wanting to tell to tell about how one of your fellow Massachusetts scenes,
Ian's has been tormenting the shopping area where my bar is located,
my blah,
um,
this all takes place in Denver,
by the way.
Yeah.
Um,
the Massachusetts is,
Ian's is first,
what do they call people from Massachusetts.
Okay.
I just pause to wait for all the be mass holes,
high five over cubicle wall.
Um,
this all takes place in Denver by the way.
His first appearance was about a week ago when he stumbled into the bar where I
work and asked me where he was.
I said the name of the bar and he said,
no,
what state?
Cont uh,
Jesus,
he goes,
I asked him why he called me a cunt and he said,
people say it all the time where he's from,
which he said was Massachusetts.
I kicked him out.
This guy sounds like a good guy.
Um,
he says,
as a side note,
I spent a week in the New England area and everyone was nice even in Boston.
Um,
anyway,
a few days later he came back when I wasn't working and drank until he insulted
the bar owner's wife,
I guess.
He went up to her and said,
what are you pregnant?
She was not,
she told him that that was rude and he called her a pregnant,
uh,
Jesus.
How many fucking bridges of this guy burned before he decided he had to go west?
Well,
there was a bunch of other people didn't realize what a Dicky was.
Anyways,
he got kicked out.
I guess he'd been getting into a lot of trouble at the liquor store nearest to
anyways,
last night he came in,
I told him he wasn't welcomed anymore.
He asked why.
I reminded him why.
Then he started making fun of people from Colorado and a stereotypical hippie
voice.
He said he thought we were all chill,
Bro,
not so uptight,
man.
Then he gave me the peace sign with his fingers and left or like his middle
fingers.
What was he doing?
I don't know.
It's funny because he has a pony tail and is filthy and calls everyone in
Colorado.
Hippies.
Yeah.
Uh,
well,
it's nice to know.
Yeah.
You got to just set a guy from Massachusetts,
moved to Colorado.
You didn't really have to go into all of that detail.
Yeah.
You know,
what kind of,
uh,
does he sound any worse than me?
No.
I have a horrific need to be liked,
so I wouldn't do something like that.
I would if I got drunk enough,
but then the next day I'd be like,
all right,
I need,
I need to lay off that shit.
You know?
I Dunno what the fuck to talk about at this point.
People,
I'm 40,
I'm not even 40 minutes.
Then
honestly,
people,
if it didn't have to go to the fucking airport,
I would have raised this entire thing.
I would,
I don't know what I would do.
I'd go sleep for fucking six hours and I would start over again,
but I don't have those options.
You know,
this is the same thing of when Geraldo opened that vault and it was live and
there was just nothing,
nothing in it.
That's what this is.
This is the Geraldo Rivera episode of the Monday morning fucking podcast.
Um,
I didn't know what to do at this point.
You guys want to talk about some topical Shit?
Did you guys see that jet blue pilot then went fucking absolutely crazy?
Was it jet blue?
I don't know.
And then everybody had to tackle him and fucking restrain him.
I don't know how I feel I would feel about that.
You know,
I know the guys going nuts but I don't know how to fly the plane so I just cut
down the amount of people who can land this thing by 50%.
Like the level of nuts that he would have to be.
They'd just be something,
you know,
there's just something about those.
Uh,
let's like John Travolta was on the flight.
He knows how to land one of those things,
you know,
I bet he's not scared to fly
cause he like knows what's going on and if anything bad happened,
right.
Why do they have to have those secret service for you?
Why don't we just get like a bunch of John Travolta's to ride on there in case
one of those nine 11 shit happens again,
right?
Aren't there a lot of movie stars and hot fly planes?
Oh my God.
I swear to God like I should be choked to death by fucking mic cord right now.
I'm literally out of comedy.
I think I just officially dried up everybody,
which is really sad because I had such a wonderful weekend,
wonderful weekend of riffing and new hour of Shit.
Maybe that's what it is and right now I'm tempted to start doing those jokes to
somehow get,
are we up to 40?
We have 40 minutes and 35 seconds.
And listen guys,
you guys have favorite TV shows out there?
Sure.
We all do to every once in a while.
Don't they just have bad episodes like yeah,
and he didn't really like that one.
I think this is the one,
although I bet you guys are somehow perversely enjoying this one.
Um,
materialists,
top five items.
This guy says,
Yo bill being the materialistic bastard that I am,
I've developed a top five essential items list for my capitalist lifestyle.
I spare no expense on these items as I believe them to be necessary for my
continued happiness.
My five items are in no particular order,
they are number one by the way,
this is how it's done in America.
All right?
So the rest he try and keep up.
If you've got the money,
buy this shit.
If you don't,
you live in some third world country and I want to say thank you for making all
this shit at 12 cents an hour.
All right?
Number One,
TV,
70 71 inch,
Samsung DLP,
okay,
number two,
and adjustable firmness bed is this American psycho sending me this shit?
Number three,
a cell phone.
The latest iPhone number four,
two ply toilet paper.
Sharman number five,
classic vehicles from the 60s [inaudible] 68 Oldsmobile convertible as 69 Jaguar
e type,
uh,
64 amp fee.
Car Amphibious.
What are your top five items and why?
Okay.
It's for just materialistic.
Selfish Shit.
All right,
I'd agree with you.
Number one has to be a TV because that's how you connect to the world.
And if I'm not connected to the world,
I'm going to be doing jokes about shit nobody knows about and then I'm not going
to be able to afford my fucking materialistic lifestyle.
So I'll give you that.
Okay.
Uh,
fuck.
Okay.
You know what?
I don't like your list then you go with the bed.
I need to watch TV than I need to sleep.
Yeah.
I'm not going that way.
I would go,
uh,
I dunno.
Fucking top of the line.
V Drums.
Okay.
A Gibson SG.
I fucking f 100.
I don't know.
Oh my God guys,
I am,
I think I just retired from comedy.
I have nothing.
I have absolutely zero funny.
You know what?
Fuck is a materialistic.
How about your top five survivalist?
You don't
first things first.
Number one,
you need a gun.
Okay.
Because you don't have a fucking gun.
You can't,
yeah.
Get anything you need or protect the shit you have.
So number one,
you got to get a gun.
Okay?
Number two,
if you're murmuring in the background,
that's Joe to rose in the other room.
I should have brought to Mike's.
Maybe they could have shot the shit with him.
My hung over fucking state number two is,
uh,
why
number two would be water.
You know,
you can go fucking 40 days without food.
Isn't that what Jesus did?
Isn't that why he was so shredded his whole life?
Every 40 days?
You look good.
You're going to a two.
What I want you to do,
I think we'll go starve myself.
Okay?
I fucking hate every one of those God damn stories of some biblical figure who
suffering from me so I can live better.
I didn't fucking ask you to do it all right?
I didn't go fucking eat something or do it for me and shut your face.
You know I can't eat like I can't.
I've thought about dying a lot lately and I was thinking,
am I going to be that guy on my deathbed who then goes a hail Mary,
full grace,
blah,
blah.
And it does all those prayers.
I don't think I'm going to be,
cause I really truly find it that fucking ridiculous.
You know,
I dunno where you'd go.
All right?
But wherever I go,
nobody's mad at me.
I haven't been there yet.
All right.
They're sitting in some of this fucking dimension watching my life.
Why would you do that?
You know?
When did you just be fucking playing baseball and your dimension or whatever the
fuck it is you do over there?
Why would you give a shit what I'm doing?
Oh,
look at this guy in Besalyn who gives a shit.
I don't know.
I don't fucking know.
What am I talking about,
right?
Number one,
I get a gun.
Number two,
fresh freshwater.
Number three,
uh,
you got to get food.
Now I need some sort of shelter.
Number five's a windmill number.
Five's a wild card.
I think that does.
Fifth one really lets people know what kind of a survivalist you are.
You know,
if you say number five,
you know,
I want a boat,
you're definitely romantic.
If you say,
I want a windmill,
you like cookies?
Uh
Oh guys,
I'm going to get a gun.
You know,
and my lady doesn't want me to get one.
All right.
Ever since I got a house I h I just feel like you're out of your fucking mind if
you don't have a gun.
You know what I mean?
It's just like,
like,
why do you,
I'm in this apartment building right now and this just all like,
you know,
there's like five fucking floors,
a human beings that you have to get through before you get to me.
Okay.
I'm in my fucking house.
It's just me.
I'm just sitting there
where,
where is the safety that there's other houses around me?
I guess that I don't know what it is.
Just being like the only person
you know,
like I'm not in charge of this fucking building.
I find that very comforting.
I come and I go,
nobody gives,
you know,
it's no problem.
The security,
there's this cameras that are all that type of shit.
I got to,
I gotta go a little Ted Nugent here.
I really want to secure around my perimeter as they say.
Plus I like guns.
I think they're cool.
Okay.
Where do you guys think you guys into guns?
You're not into guns.
We're going to take college at this point.
Why don't I do what?
Just turn to make this into a live fucking podcast.
Oh God,
I'll fucking beyond hung over.
Why do I do it?
I'm going to blame Farsi fucking animal.
Glue it back to his house at like two 30 in the morning.
Fucking pours me a whiskey.
Right?
It gets out some rum.
It makes a giant rum and coke.
Lucky some fucking sophomore in college,
pledging a Sorority,
kind of a man.
Drinks rum and cokes.
I'll tell you who Paul [inaudible],
Paul brizy drinks.
He drinks them in a big beer glass too,
to show how fucking uncultured he is.
Yeah,
so I'm sitting there,
I'm drinking is fucking Scotch,
right?
I would have fucking gave me,
and he's trying to tell me I should finish the bottle and I'm like,
I can't.
I get fucking radio in the morning.
He's like,
dude,
there's no fucking way you making it to the radio.
Cause had to be up at like seven 30.
It was already two 30 in the morning.
But I'll tell you I was up at seven 30 and he proceeded to fucking
go on this rant about Irish people.
Like how he is an Italian.
Oh will fucking what the what?
He's Greek and and uh,
we said a little line when this Sicilian,
how does,
you know he gives you fucking Irish guys.
You'd drink til four in the morning and you've gotta be up at seven.
He just fucking up at seven.
You guys can take a punch.
That's what he said.
You know,
I don't know.
I don't believe that.
I think there's plenty of fucking half Greek half Sicilians.
They could fucking drink til four in the morning to get up.
You know what the problem,
the verse he gives,
he doesn't want it.
Guy Doesn't want it.
It doesn't have the fucking hard but you got out of the heart when you fucking
drink,
you know,
set the worst feeling ever.
Those last three drinks we just know how fucking stupid you being.
You start laughing with your friends.
You get like that group self sabotage going on.
Hey,
this is really fucking stupid,
isn't it?
Um,
anyways,
let's get to underrated overrated.
As I tried to turn on this fucking iPad for the 15th time,
I gotta be honest with you.
A overrated Steve Jobs.
I just don't see what the fuck that guy did that was so god damn important that
I read everything here very to break up with his girlfriend.
Oh Hey,
here's where the emails every week and I swear to God every week,
everybody next week's going to be a funny podcast.
Not this one.
You know what this podcast feels like.
It feels like there was some sort of unbelievable tragedy and I still had to
come on the air and I was expecting some sort of,
you know,
major guest and they just didn't show up.
And we're still looking at the wreckage,
the wreckage of my fucking podcast.
Bill a,
what do we got here?
Um,
Oh,
if you wanna email me,
which I don't know why he would have to this podcast on the email is
bill@themmpodcast.com.
Uh,
we also have a donation button on the podcast if you want to donate.
how about some advertising?
I get how you get these fucking things.
What can I do?
At least do something right?
Or are we all right?
Here we go.
Here we come up though.
You can do,
you can do it.
All right.
Game fly.com everybody.
Alright.
This is the best way to rent video games and,
and this one has been doing,
it's been fucking asis on the podcast.
Everybody responding to gain fly.com is the best way to rent video games.
If you are new to my podcast and you are a Gamer,
all right?
Wouldn't it be great to have 8,000 video games at your fingertips when it be
great if they give deal to be delivered right to your front door already a
Goddamn PC when that be phenomenal.
No late fees.
You can cancel anytime,
uh,
going through the Monday morning podcast listeners,
get a 15 day free trial,
15 days.
That's two weeks and a day for those keeping score at home.
You get 8,000 games.
Take two weeks of once you that quit your job,
be a man,
had the balls of the balls to live dangerously.
Just walk in and say,
you know what?
Fuck this job and fuck you.
What are you going to do with you life,
man?
I'm gonna go play video games for 15 days and then I'm going to figure it out.
Okay?
And you know what you're going to be doing after 15 days,
still sitting at that desk,
Kate and you fucking life.
By the way,
your wife always has bad breath.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Um,
Monday morning podcast listeners,
get a 15 day free trial.
Go to www dot [inaudible] dot com slash bur bur are to activate this special
offer.
All right?
I think that's it for the advertising.
I didn't skate fenders where they Kinda,
they dropped the advertising on this podcast because they were so offended by
the,
the unbelievable,
unbelievable lack of funny on this pocket.
I can't even fucking talk this week.
Um,
no,
not enough people bought the scape fenders and I'm gonna tell you something.
You fucking missed out.
Oh,
I didn't talk about hockey last week.
I told you guys that I've been starting to put some shit together here after a
year and a half a plan.
I don't know what's going on.
Oh,
Billy boys starting to trust his edges out there.
Okay.
Last week I actually had,
I had a goal for the first time and I can't since maybe January
I had a goal.
It's coming down the left wing.
Puck came right across the crease.
I had like almost no angle whatsoever.
I saw the open space and I flipped it and somehow the fucking puck went right up
and over the goalies shoulder into the net.
Exactly what I wanted to have happened happened and you know,
it's pickup [inaudible] nobody really celebrates goals because there's like 20
scored on each side.
But I was just such an excited little girl.
I put my fucking arms up like,
you know,
when Messier guaranteed the victory against the devils,
which is glide behind the net with his arms straight up.
I was waiting for the roar of the crowd.
Everyone else just sort of skated back,
you know and started going the other directions as I sat there with you know,
you know it's the same thing Joe Montana used to do when there was a touchdown.
There's no bending at the elbows.
You just bring them straight up like like Charlie Brown when he yells.
That's what I did and I'm so psyched I got one early.
Okay this is not well just how much I've gotten into hockey.
I've actually gone on Youtube and I've been watching this guy and he has a,
he almost does like the John Madden thing cause my big,
my biggest problem aside from sucking at stick handling,
skating and all aspects of the game is just the overall question of where the
fuck am I supposed to be out there?
And I just watched this guys,
okay this guy's videos,
I'll watch like 45 minutes of videos.
Just absorbing a little bit from each video about how to do a breakout,
where to be on a power play and even though it's dope power plays,
whatever,
just basic fundamental shit.
Is it defensive as a forward cycling it around drills.
Just shit like that.
And I actually got a compliment last week said,
you know what,
you're,
you're decent positional player.
You still suck when we send you the puck.
I just fucking,
I can't stick handle for my life,
but I kind of know where to be now,
which means more people pass to me and then I fuck up even more.
Dude,
do you want to talk about panicking with the puck?
I was joking with opie today on the,
on the uh,
the a program,
uh,
about that FD if you have,
she had a heart monitor hooked up to my,
my whatever.
My wrist with a pulse is act.
Is that what it is?
I don't fucking know my elbow like how,
I bet it goes up like 30 beats a fucking minute the second I get the puck and
people always try to help me out.
No one around your plenty times y'all,
you got plenty of time.
And I immediately
like just blindly pass it and I just feel everyone on my team,
just God,
this fucking guy,
why does he keep showing up?
But anyways,
so I got a goal and uh,
it was a fucking sharp shoot if I do say so myself.
So now I'm excited.
I got a little spring in my step.
We play for an hour and a half.
About an hour later I have some on a breakout.
I get the fucking puck.
I went around to defensemen,
swear to God.
I don't know how I did it.
I was looking down at the ice.
That's how I stick handle faked out one faked out the other.
Got The goalie leaning all the way to the right.
I got half the net wide open.
I'm like holy fuck.
Two goals in one game of pickup in 90 minutes for player of my caliber would
have been like,
it would've been the equivalent of when Gretzky scored 50 goals in 39 games.
It was fucking wide open and I flipped it.
It was going right to the net and the goalie at the last second stuck his hand
out and just fucking snatched it out of the air.
Everybody the eyes.
Oh.
And then that was it.
I was still one goal.
Billy just fucking horrible.
And I gotta tell you something that bugged me for three God damn days.
It was literally,
do you ever watch when you watch a fucking hockey game and they have those
little eight year olds,
you know,
they stick,
handle no escape.
That's what I look like.
They're actually better than me.
I would say like a six year old.
I don't know if I'm peewee level of squirts.
I never paid organized,
but uh,
I dunno.
I'm really enjoying that.
I,
I plan on playing the game and I got to tell you,
I've been wearing those scape fenders things if people for it first,
we'll make it fun of me.
And now that you kind of going like,
you know,
I've seen guys,
I've seen players wearing them in the NHL,
did the fucking shit.
I got hit in the foot during the game.
I finally took one off the foot.
I don't know where I took it.
I don't know how hard it was.
It had no effect it,
it felt lighter than if I got hit in like the sh I felt it more than the ship at
all.
His nothing happened to me this whole fucking slow.
I am.
I was trying to get back on defense.
Like I can skate backwards but not nearly fast enough.
So what always happens is,
is ice skate backwards for about three feet before I have to immediately turn
around and,
and I immediately,
I,
and I'm so slow,
I look like I'm part of the offensive break rather than the person trying to
stop it on defense.
So I went into the offensive,
there are offensive zone.
My,
my what I'm supposed to be defending and a,
this is when you know you're slow,
when you take a slap shot in the ass.
That's how slow I was on defense.
I got anything literally hit in the ass.
It was just below the s,
you know the referees,
you know,
it was like in when you,
you got to see if you've got a first down or not.
It was not quite a fucking first down to just bust my ass.
And there is no padding there whatsoever.
Thank God.
It was just a risk though.
Um,
but I'm not going to lie to you.
It fucking hurt like hell.
But there was no way I was going to show it.
The dude,
fuck it hit me.
It just goes,
ah.
And everyone laughed and I had to pretend like it didn't fucking happen.
Ah,
so close to the glory of fucking two goals.
And then I get,
I,
I missed the second one and then I get fucking hit in the ass of the pocket.
I just go right back to being the Douche bag,
you know?
So anyways,
so this is the deal.
So I'm loving the fucking games,
the greatest Goddamn game.
Don't think you're too old to take it up.
I took it up and fucking 42 I'm having a time in my life and I'm joining a
fucking league.
Oh my God,
who just walked into the room out of the bedroom,
the sensation,
the teen idols sensation wearing a fucking leather coat to match Joe to Rosa.
Joe,
how the fuck I have a seat?
I know you can't just have a seat sale up.
Joe,
you haven't been on the podcast forever.
How are you man?
I remember we used to do radio show.
I remember Bill Joe.
Those were the days we used to sing songs.
We used to talk about things or let me tell you around here.
No,
I'm not.
It's,
it's horrible.
it's hot as fuck.
I've just been,
I've been brutally unfunny.
I'm hung over this whole podcast.
I've been just apologizing,
shitting all over how unfunny what's it until like I just told the story about
playing hockey and that I think that that was mildly amusing and that made me
laugh was I see singing out here.
Oh,
you know what I was singing about?
I was singing some guy who was trying to figure out how to break up with his
girl and not hurt her feelings.
She's some girl,
she was like depressed all the time.
He has to keep her going.
I mean it's a no brainer.
He's 23 years old,
right?
Yeah.
Jesus.
Joe,
23 years old.
Joe Did the,
everybody's in sensation at that age.
Okay.
All right.
But it is not that young man's responsibility to take on her problem.
She's got to work those things out and when she loves her shelf,
then she can love you
Joe Fucking de Rosa.
That,
I mean that's,
I was trying to get to that point for fucking 10 minutes.
That's it.
Joe.
I don't,
Joe,
you've had one girlfriend that I've known you for eight years.
Joe Is the master of just not even getting into relationships or they'll you,
you're the master of like what the three week relationship.
I usually go a couple of months.
Yeah,
something like that.
I don't get too,
uh,
too serious,
but I think I'm ready now.
I think I'm moving into that.
I don't care about that.
This isn't about you.
It's about this.
So at two,
two months in,
that's got to be a small box of shit that you have to pack up when they come
over to get their stuff.
Am I wrong?
I mean,
I don't even think you're on a phone call to what's it?
You could do it over the phone at two months.
I've done that.
I've done that too.
Oh,
you do the fade away?
Yeah.
You just disappear.
Like Kevin Spacey walking down the street.
If you have the usual suspects,
just straightly all leg out and off he goes.
Ah.
He goes,
where are you off to Joe?
I got a meeting at Atlantic records.
They built all the sensation.
He's going over there.
Joe,
don't get now.
Don't walk in there and get all star struck with all those albums on the wall.
Okay.
Nobody buys those anymore.
You're walking into a dinosaur,
Joe.
They need you.
That's right.
Okay.
Let me hear you say it.
Oh,
I'll say you need me.
You need me.
Mr Atlantic,
Mister and Mrs Atlantic records.
You are,
I'll say you think I'm impressed.
I got go birds sitting on my couch.
[inaudible] suckers.
Yeah.
That's how you started.
Exactly.
Don't Chevy Chase on him.
I'll see you when I get home bill.
All right Joseph.
Hey Joe.
Maybe we'll have a couple of pops before I go to the airport,
but it'll have her the dog there.
Ah,
Christ.
This is,
you know,
I really want it to be healthy on this road trip,
but this is one of these ones we just say,
you know,
we just have fucked up so bad.
You just,
you just ended like buzzed eating a pint of ice cream.
Go on.
You know what?
Maybe the next one.
I'd like to think that I may be pulled this one out in the end.
You know,
talking about my love of hockey.
How great.
He's Joe de Rosa.
Huh?
You telling me that that guy just isn't a ray of sunshine,
you know,
that's why he's called the sensation Joey roses.
He makes it fucking blow.
Um,
is there anything else to talk about?
Do I really need to go beyond a fucking hour on this?
I don't think I do.
People.
I apologize for the fucking hung over one,
but you know something.
You went all of 2011 without one.
I'm trying to think the last time I was hung over on a podcast.
I think it's been a long time.
It's been a while since you fucking whatever ever that guy stayed.
I used to sing about his dad.
Remember that?
Um,
anyways,
that's the podcast for this week.
You guys.
I know it was late and I know it wasn't worth the wait.
So you don't need,
you don't even need to tell me.
I know.
All right.
Don't be one of those Douche bags.
You know like when you fucking get arrested for drinking and driving and then
your friend shows up and tells you how fucking stupid you are.
Like you didn't realize that when you spent the night in jail with no sneakers
on cause he thought you're going to hang yourself by your shoe laces.
Like if he couldn't figure out that point,
do you think I really need you to tell me that you do?
Okay.
All right.
I don't even what that means.
That's a podcast for this week.
Go fuck yourselves.
I will talk to you next week.
And,
um,
yeah,
that's it.
Go Fuck Yourself.